first one of this a few words about the
brain and computation program in general
and the goal of this program is to bring
these two fields computation computer
science and neuroscience together they
they have very deep tides in their roots
going back more than half a century yep
they've sort of grown apart and growing
independently over the years and
different different departments
different curricula and so forth and
many of us recognize that that these
deep ties still exist and this is a this
is really an opportunity to Kindle those
to reformulate those by bringing experts
together from both sides from
neuroscience and from computer science
there's three in addition to the boot
camp today there's three workshops that
will be taking place as part of the
program that are posted on the website a
few words about the the boot camp today
it's called a boot camp no push-ups
required but you will be mentally
expanding your horizons here and so
mental push-ups in terms of like
learning stretching your brain and
learnings been learning about something
new that's really that's really the goal
here we've we've inserted so yeah the
idea is really that in in the boot camp
to introduce the fundamentals from both
sides from computation and from
neuroscience and that this will form the
basis of collaboration in interactions
that will occur throughout the term ok
but to do that we really have to sort of
have to get up to speed on a lot of
stuff that any of us don't know about
yet we've asked the speakers to to keep
these two talks tutorial in nature and
specifically given in the instruction
that that experts in their field should
be bored so if you are bored try not to
look for
just encourage them to something more
exciting been dressing you right so this
is going to integrate really tutorial in
nature and okay so the the program the
way we set it up is to really kind of
have alternating days of neuroscience
and computation so today is on the
neuroscience side starting from the
cellular end at Jeff Lichtman about
connectomics and looking at sort of
wiring and detailed connectivity in the
brain and also large scale databases in
neuroscience this is from the from the
Allen Institute tomorrow then we'll move
to the computational size of Bartlett
mill is going to be telling us about
computational models of single neurons
basically the biophysics of computation
and Wolfgang Moss on computational
models of neural circuits and then and
then on Thursday we'll switch back to
neuroscience with Maurice Sherman
talking about the thalamocortical system
and the afternoon when a teen talking
about motor systems and myself on
envision and then Friday is sort of back
to back to computation and what kind of
sort of moving from the cellular side to
the to the grand and sort of theoretical
big-picture questions so Christoph
Pappas Mitra is going to give us a a
kind and gentle introduction to theory
of computation and that will be boring
to the computer scientists right and
then Santosh kampala I'm also taking is
that same idea about taking in the wrong
machine learning is a release to
computational neuroscience
then Peggy serious who's gonna be
talking about you know Bayesian models a
perception cognition okay so that's
that's what's ahead this week so today's
speaker it's real real pleasure and
honor to have Jeff here with us I think
the best way to introduce Jeff is from
something he said and an article like we
interview every single bed with him what
he said is I really like looking at data
okay so that sort of says it all this is
this is this is where somebody likes to
do look at data and so what he's been
spending his career doing is getting
that data basically just say perfecting
the techniques that enable to us to peer
into the brain and look at brain
structures on a very fine scale he did
his graduate work with Dale curves at
Washington University in st. Louis and I
think that was the first back up this
faculty position there and where he was
really an early developer and pioneer of
the two-photon imaging techniques
applying that method to studying neural
development to the new birth
neuromuscular Junction and of course
that's that technique is now really sort
of bread and butter a standard technique
today in many labs and and now at
Harvard University he has been doing all
kinds of amazing things but among them
they develop the brain bow technique
which enables one to have neurons that
light up and a variety of different
colors according to which proteins on
the Express and he's gonna be showing
this lots of those colorful pictures
today so thanks very much for coming
[Applause]
so can everybody hear me thank you very
much Bruno it's a pleasure to be here
especially this month because Boston and
Cambridge ship in horrible it's so hot
here I'm sweating and it's been a long
time since I felt sweat I am a biologist
I'm assuming most of you are not
biologists and so my goal I think is to
give you a biological perspective of
data with the full understanding that I
believe that biologists are inadequately
trained to actually do anything with
this data other than look at it and it
when you say like to look at data you
are literally correct I like to look at
data with my eyes this is not the way to
get deep insights probably in
neuroscience there you learn a good deal
from looking but there is probably in
this data much more and this is going to
require a generation of what I would
call neuro scientists although you might
call yourself computational biologists
to look at data in a more serious
quantitative way I want to begin with
something that many of you probably are
not fully aware of about biology that
there's two kinds of biology and they're
related in something in a way that I
think I have formulated at least for
myself a new formulation I hope you
haven't heard this before to think about
the way these two styles of biology are
and you hear a lot of biology that is of
one style or the other and you probably
don't realize how they're linked and
this is the science you does has anyone
heard of the science you great okay so I
think this is my idea it's not a
profound idea but it is an idea and the
idea of the science you here's that you
is that in biology there are lots of
phenomena things in the real world that
are interesting that a kind of biologist
reduces to its elemental explanation
this is a
a step on the way down where you
understand the phenomenon by breaking it
down and then once you've understood it
this information is leveraged you get
the explanation and then you leverage it
by gaining information and building up
to a synthesis of using that information
this may seem very abstract but I'm
going to give you a few examples and by
the way do interrupt me if anything I
say is confusing I'm sure there will be
rather than just having the questions at
the end just stop me because there it's
more important that what I say you
understand then that I get through all
my slides so let's take an example you
probably know if you took a high school
biology course that this guy Gregor
Mendel discovered that the color of the
flower of a pea was related to the
colors of the flowers of the parents
peas that he was putting together that
there was some kind of inheritance of
color that came from parents and it
wasn't just in peas it's also in people
of course the color of your hair or the
color of your eyes etc and that meant
that there must be some physical basis
for inheritance and that led over
hundreds of years inextricably to an
atomic explanation of what the physical
basis of inheritance was and that was
Watson and Crick's discovery of the way
DNA is structured that was a tremendous
form of reduction and it gets you down
to a basal level of atomic structure of
DNA and then that once you've accepted
that then you might say well all the
physical inheritances that go on in an
animal are based on what is in that DNA
and then a field was born called
genomics where all that information is
now played out for not just different
species but even different individuals
of one species so here's the way down
and the way back up that's sort of
straightforward so some scientists are
very much synthesizing information this
way and other scientists in the biology
biological realm are working very hard
to get it mechanism
and people don't start their lecture and
saying yeah I'm on this side of the U or
this side of the U you don't hear that
so you sometimes get confused about how
what kind of science a computer
scientist can be most useful for
interestingly on the way back up it's
not just sorting out the names of each
of the genes but lots of discoveries are
made like repetitive non-coding DNA
maternal and parental imprinting things
that were not inferred on the way down
that get built up on the way up so the
synthesis actually generates new ideas
which they themselves can lead to other
use and other ideas moving on and on and
on so there's a lot more to this than
just building up information another
example is there are diseases phenomena
in the world doctors and scientists
biochemists often go to try to figure
out what the disease is they get the
cause and then once they have the cause
they get a treatment that's another
example of this you one more relevant
maybe to computer science is that
perception is a phenomenon that humans
undertake with our visual systems for
some people one of the deep insights
into perception was this hierarchical
arrangement that Hubel and Wiesel
discovered of the complex receptive
fields emerging from simpler ones this
is not something I'm going to talk about
today but probably this will in your
vision stuff you'll talk about this idea
has a lot of legs in the sense that it
provides a way of thinking about
perception as being broken down in a
series of hierarchical steps and that in
excited computer scientists and I think
convolutional neural nets to some degree
are inspired by this so here's the way
down and here's the way back up and a
lot of artificial learning can be traced
back to these ideas
well I'm most interested in is that the
brain is itself not a homogeneous piece
of protoplasm it's made up of individual
entities known as cells or neurons and
one of the reductions that is very
interesting about these is the fact that
these cells are connected together in a
directional network and this is cajas
law of dynamic polarization I'm going to
explain this in great detail so don't
worry about it if this doesn't sound
like anything right now but this is the
idea that nerve cells are not just
connected willy-nilly but there's a an
idea behind the way they're connected
and if you accept that the brain is
basically a big wiring diagram then you
would want to synthesize as going from
DNA to genomics going from these
individual idea of connections to
connect omics and so this is where I see
this field which I will describe in in
good detail for you in a minute
and who knows as one begins to describe
these wiring diagrams what will turn up
that was not inferred already from the
work of going from cells to this wiring
diagram idea everybody okay anyone
confused yet okay so let's talk about
aha and what he did so qahal is
sometimes called the father of
neuroscientist
he certainly is the the mother of all
neuroscientists he is the beginner of
the idea of neuroscience and he was a he
was a kind of visual genius he used a
very specific stain called the Golgi
stain and with the Golgi stain which is
a stain that is extraordinarily powerful
by virtue of the fact that it only
labels a very small percentage of nerve
cells but it labels those cells in their
entirety he could just by looking and
that's because of his geniusness he
inferred something about the way nerve
cells were connected
and here's an example of one of his
drawings the paper has gotten yellow and
he used whiteout he's very meticulous
drawer and he drew thousands and
thousands of pictures so ignore this
white stuff here that's just places
where he corrected his drawings and this
is a Golgi stain picture of a piece of
cerebral cortex where these objects here
are nerve cells and this thing in the
middle of each of them is their nucleus
every cell has a single nucleus and he
has these wires going around and you
notice these arrows the arrows were the
brilliant thing this he was a stable
genius absolutely he did everything he
did was really interesting and this was
one of his ideas now this was not based
on knowing about synapses or action
potentials or any electrophysiology this
was just looking at the Golgi stain and
what he said is that nerve cells have
little processes sticking out of them
these fat things here which we call
dendrites and these dendrites are
receiving information from axons that
come from other places so this arrow is
from a wire from a cell somewhere maybe
over here that has an axon that comes up
here in branches and its branches
overlap the branches of the dendrites of
this cell and he inferred just by
looking at the static dead material that
these accents are probably releasing
something on in some way to cause the
dendrites to receive information from
the axon the dendrites then send that
information to the cell body of the cell
and then the cell body has a single
process coming out of it which is
another axon like this one that axon
goes up and touches the in this case the
apical the highest dendrites of this
cell it's a pyramidal neuron that's the
name of this kind of cell and that
information then flows into that apical
dendrite towards the cell body and
here's another axon that touches the
more basal dendrites of the same cell
and it also sends information into this
cell body and together these inputs
somehow collaborate to generate a signal
that leaves
sell out its axon and axon touches the
dendrites of this cell that information
flows out its axon that axon also
touches the dendrites of this cell and
that information flows out that X and
then here in one fell swoop was this
theory about the way nerve cells talk to
each other and no one had ever said that
before and it's not a hard idea almost
anyone can understand it in a
rudimentary sense and to this day it is
a very powerful way for thinking about
the nervous system this was his big idea
and even though this was done in the
1890s I think most people today still
think about nerve cell connectivity
something like this there's many
additions to what he saw for example all
of this is pushing information forward
there's no inhibition in here and we now
know many of the connections in the
nervous system are designed actually to
shut cells up this cell for example is
more likely to be an inhibitory neuron
that's not trying to encourage the cell
to send information but trying to keep
the cell silent but he didn't know that
and so there is no inhibition in these
drugs
now this big idea has a big implication
for thinking about behavior you probably
already could infer this but cahal made
this explicit he said behavior is
basically a chain of causality of
information going from sensory systems
out to motor systems so in this drawing
he said here's some skin that has
sensory endings in it of a kind that
send information into the brain here's
the cell body and so the information if
you scratch the skin or you put your
hand on a hot plate that information
goes in through a particular type of
nerve cell into the spinal cord and some
of those processes go up into the brain
stem where they touch the dendrites of
brain stem neurons and those neurons
send information up into the cerebral
cortex where those axons touch the
dendrites of pyramidal neurons those
pyramidal neurons then send the
information back down to the spinal cord
and touch the dendrites of motor neurons
and those motor neurons send their
accent and cause muscle fibers to
contract and this might be why you would
pull your hand away it would be on the
same side in that case but but if this
would be the kind of pathway where a
sensory stimulation would give rise to a
motor output you could generalize this
and say you're driving along and
suddenly the light turns red and
information forces your leg muscles to
push on the brake it's the same idea
and again to a first approximation many
scientists think this is a reasonable
approach although clearly nobody has
seen this to occur over this long a
distance but there is not a better sort
of general idea at the moment but but
that doesn't make this true it just
means it's the hypothesis under which
modern neuroscientists at least
biologists believe information flows is
this okay
so what are the fundamentals of this
idea so I just want to go through four
principles they're axioms of
Neurobiology that have come from Ramon
eco-house influence he was a Spanish
neuroscientist and the cahal method the
Golgi stain was an Italian
neuroscientist cahal and Golgi shared
the Nobel Prize but hated each other
completely and if you want to read
something funny you could read gol G's
Nobel lecture where he simply says cause
a complete idiot and completely
misinterpreted that all the Golgi
staying material so yeah I would say
even at the beginning there were
controversies but but we remember Golgi
for the stain not for disagreeing with
kaha and we remember call for call for
these lasting influences these axioms of
Neurobiology
axioms in biology are not like axioms in
mathematics you can have exceptions it's
no problem they're just sort of we call
them axioms that they're not axioms but
here are the axioms the first is that
the basic unit of organization of the
brain is the neuron this is one of
Kyle's terms the neuron doctrine that
information flows from neuron to neuron
to neuron to neuron in some kind of
cascade that's the first idea the second
is that the nervous system is not made
up of one type of cell that's just inter
digitated with itself over and over
again but that different kinds of
neurons have different shapes I've
already shown you the pyramidal shape of
the pyramidal neuron that sensory neuron
had a weird shape where the cell body is
sort of sitting out up to the side and
the information flows from the skin into
the central nervous system and sort of
bypasses the cell body it and that there
must be many types of cells in the brain
all of these are neurons but they each
have their own local structure and
connectional information that make them
separate from other types the third idea
of which I've already talked about is
this law of dynamic polarization that
axons send information to the dendrites
sometimes they send information right to
the cell
and then the information flows out the
cells axon so it comes into the
dendrites via the axons of other cells
and then it goes out the cells own axon
to touch the dendrites of other cells
that's the law of dynamic polarization
okay and then finally the brain is not
just a random set of connections but
that there are canonical circuits
canonical as in the word Canon that they
are the same in one person as opposed to
another people are interested in what is
the canonical circuit in the cerebral
cortex or in the visual system of the
cerebral cortex or in the hippocampus or
in other parts of the brain what are
these canonical circuits
these are axioms that a lot of people
are after getting the underlying details
about I am NOT expressing my view about
these I don't think just because they're
his they're not my personal ones and you
may get to hear me poop on virtually
every one of these before the end of
today but I want you to understand that
this is where neuroscience believes
based on qahal at least there's food for
a further analysis and so if one wants
to deal with all this one's going to
have to map out all these wiring
diagrams and that's this field known as
connectomics
this word connectomics is maybe
unfamiliar to some of you maybe by now
you've heard of it this is the
dictionary definition from
merriam-webster's on a bridge 2019 what
we made up this definition in 2008 we
thought you know maybe there's a chance
this will be in the dictionary by 2019
I don't think it'll be in the dictionary
2019 but but this is the idea of
connectomics it's sometimes pronounced
connectomics other neuroscientists
pronounce it connectomics it's a
singular noun
but plural and constructions so it's
like economics it's got an S at the end
but it's a Singh
and it's a branch of biotechnology
concerned with applying the techniques
of computer assisted image acquisition
and analysis to the structural mapping
of sets of neural circuits or even to
the complete nervous system of selected
organisms using high-speed methods
you'll see why high-speed is necessary
and organizing the results in databases
and by databases here you know for a
biologist an Excel spreadsheet is sort
of like that's a Teta base but I think
we think we have to go well beyond that
for data like this first of all its
images not simply numbers so it's
complicated to put this in data places
but this is your challenge and with
applications of the data as in neurology
or psychiatry so for example you could
have wiring diagrams that are abnormal
those would be connect appa these
another word in this dictionary of the
future and you where you would want to
say that autism let's say is that
connect apathy and here's the connection
elaboration that gives rise to that
disorder and fundamental neuroscience
well if you learned what your
grandmother looked like and if I say
think of your grandmother picture of her
comes to mind somehow one might imagine
that that's built in to the wiring
diagram now and that's a fundamental
question that is not answered how is
information about the world instantiated
into a wiring diagram so that's a
fundamental neuroscience question that
could come out of connectomics and I I
made this definition by looking up the
definition of proteomics and genomics so
that's why it sounds that way and the
connectome in this definition might be
the full wiring diagram of a whole
animal or a part of a nervous system ok
no questions yet you all confused or
it's too it's you're not bored yet yeah
mostly not sleeping okay so the
aspiration of connectomics is to explore
these fundamental axioms that I just
mentioned for example the brains made up
of a lot of cell types well if you could
see every single cell
you would learn every single cell type
at least as cell types manifested in
terms of their shape and their
connections so aspiration of
connectomics is to answer the question
of how many cell types there are in the
brain you could acquire the complete
canonical circuit of any part of the
brain you wanted at the level of
synapses and this is very different from
what at present goes were a reasonable
circuit which are of these hyper sparse
cartoons neuroscientists draw to get a
sense of how a system works and get the
actual physical instantiation of
behavior as opposed to these hyper
sparse cartoons let me show you what a
hyper sparse cartoon looks like they
don't look bad this is one from Rudolfo
Yi nos and colleagues it's it's actually
a to some degree reasonable it's very
Kali and these are cells in the thalamus
that send their axons up to the cortex
see these arrows and these axons make
synapses on to the dendrites of
pyramidal neurons and the information
flows out of the neuron out its axon
back down to the thalamus and he's added
now because we now know these exists not
only the direct connections but these
inhibitory interneurons these
feed-forward inhibition circuits as well
so here is a hyper sparse cartoon this
is not what the brain actually is this
is a human attempt to turn a massively
complicated wiring diagram into
something that's digestible by a human
brain and that is a question whether
that's a reasonable thing to want to do
but this is what everybody does so you
see drawings like this all the time all
through the nervous system and this is
not just a issue of sort of the nervous
system being a place where complexity
has forced us to come up with a simple
code for what might be much more
complicated for example this neuron
might do 5,000 cells of connections not
all of which are doing the same thing
and contact inhibitory neurons that do
many many things in addition to
this all that's hidden from view because
we don't know about it so we get these
simple ideas but it's not just the
nervous system where simple circuits
replace actual circuits another example
is in molecular biology a field you're
probably not too familiar with picture
so what gives them the confidence to
draw these kind of pictures just doing
statistics so they somebody recorded
from this cell and maybe recorded from
this cell and then stimulated this cell
and found inhibition on this cell well
they might have done it 20 times and so
they say there's a probability of that
kind of connection but this is not what
the brain looks like if it did we could
get away with all we would need you even
biologists could understand this yeah
the lines they're not touching like I've
started being like an engineer these
like these are synapses I'm going to go
into gory detail about what these are
they're called synapses and they are not
in most cases they're not actually
touching there's a little gap between
them and there's a chemical called a
neurotransmitter that's released by one
and binds to receptors on the other side
there are a couple that are actually
melded together soldered together called
electrical synapses where there is no
chemical interface but most of these all
of the connections shown in this are
chemical synapses of which the majority
of synapses in the cortex are chemical
but not exclusively some are
electrically any other
questions yeah so if you're just in
performance maybe a simple diagram like
this might be enough to do what a very
complicated neural net might do is it
your opinion that you have to map it
exactly as the brain well I guess the
question is if this worked this in terms
of energy this is a lot lot easier to do
than what the brain actually does so why
is the brain going to all the trouble of
doing it so much more complicated than
this and chances are it's because this
isn't correct this is a human idea of
what the brain is doing and it's
consistent with data it's not wrong but
but when new data is generated which it
often is in connect omics virtually all
the time what scene is different from
what these models suggest and all they
do is add complexity it's not like they
erase something they just add a million
things that you didn't know about and so
that suddenly it's not so
straightforward that you have this loop
this is a simple loop that's loops are
complicated but this is a simple loop
but it could be a far far more
complicated loop but but most
neuroscientists will throw you know
rotten tomatoes at me just for saying
this because this is their bread and
butter this is the way neuroscience
works this is tractable and that there
are thousands and thousands of Papers
written on this approach this is the
paradigm we're talking about a paradigm
shift of starting to get real circuits
if we were to build a brain right but
what you would be building a brain with
is with your brain right and and it's a
common mistake I think to assume that
the logic of the machine you used to
think is the same as the logic of the
output of a brain it's not that way it's
far more complicated than what comes out
of a brain in my
view and this is the challenge it's not
it it defies simple understanding I
think we'll come back to this several
more times yes wishful thinking I think
there I mean there is a hope that there
will be some meta level of explanation
that will allow us to not have to worry
about every single synapse and
everything is different from every other
thing there is a hope and let's take it
for the idea let's say you were
interested in cities and you go to New
York and you go to Boston and you go to
Paris and you go to London and you
notice a lot of these cities have big
rivers and you start to say oh there
must be a canonical city circuit that
works and you look at each instantiation
is a little different but you try to
come up with some meta logic that
explains all these cities could a human
do that absolutely would it be correct I
don't think so because these cities are
based on many many many things besides
just rivers you could have looked at it
in another way and found that be very
different I don't I don't really know
but this is the challenge of whether
there are canonical circuits or where
everything is different in every single
brain I think you're saying this circuit
is too simple I mean you don't believe
that if you look in the visual cortex
and you move 100 microns to the right
that the circuit is completely dead oh
no so you do believe in canonical
circuits you're saying this is a drastic
oversimplification and you're going to
show beautiful pictures to prove that
but it's you know so the problem still
exists to figure out what that little
chunk of cortex is doing yeah and can
you believe be done eventually yeah I
mean I think I'm I'm slightly more
nuanced about this than that and that is
that there are two forces at work in
generating the structure of a nervous
system one of them is genetics and one
of them is experience and
the genetics generates a brain with
cells that look like pyramidal neurons
and cells that have particular der
transmitters and perhaps that a cortex
that has particular layers and that
often is said well therefore we should
be able to get the canonical circuit on
the other hand what's built into a brain
of a mammal especially a human being the
vast majority of the wiring is related
probably to what you've experienced in
life as most of your behavior most of
your repertoire is not intrinsic but
it's learned that wiring diagram is
probably different between every one of
us and may exist no matter what the
original genetics were you would still
have a wiring diagram you you listen to
these birds that can imitate human
speech perfectly amazingly they're not
using a cortex they don't even have a
cerebral cortex and yet they have the
wiring to generate the motor output
based on sensory input of speech that's
just like us so I'm not sure the
canonical circuit is really the right
thing we should be looking for anyway
because I'm not sure that's telling us
anything other than the historical
antecedents that generated a brain that
had layers rather than having the
functional interesting ability to
instantiate information I'd like to make
comment on a circuit okay think of this
is a circus to me this is just a very
very minor part of a real circuit that
does interesting computation you are
right of course because what's driving
this is coming in from somewhere else
and where this is going is somewhere
else as well
the brain itself is an extraordinarily
interconnected set of cells so that if
an ant bites your toe while I'm talking
if he bites my toe my entire
consciousness can be forced to attend to
my toe where only one or two pain fibers
were activated so it's massively
interconnected and this is just a little
eddy current
in this vast thingy and this itself is
an oversimplification so I don't have
any argument with that either okay
so in in molecular biology you have the
same idea that you go from receptor
tyrosine kinases that activate a
molecule that activates another molecule
that activates rass which is a molecule
that phosphorylase raf which then
phosphorylates mek one two that
phosphorylates kirk and that inhibits
mek and so you have these little
currents ago yeah it all makes sense
this is again the this is the the coin
of the realm I think for molecular
biology but again it's a complete under
rendering of what's actually going on
how much fan-in and fan-out there is at
each of these steps and people want to
get full transcriptomes of exactly all
the molecules involved but as soon as
you do that again you get into a
computational problem it becomes more
complicated than these hyper sparse
cartoons another goal and I've sort of
hinted at this of doing connectomics is
and looking at is just to look at the
ultra structural data per se
look maybe with more sophisticated
techniques than just your retina to seek
new biological regularities so rather
than just making wiring diagrams can we
learn things that we didn't know existed
before and so in so in principle for me
at least connectomics is a bottom-up
approach it shows what is there
physically in the brain independent of
what theories exist it generates the
data upon which theories can be
generated in response to it as opposed
to simply being there to test whether
the theories we already have are correct
or not and this is again an area of
tension right now I think most people
who are doing connectomics are not doing
it from the bottom-up they have some
theory about how the brain works and
they're using connectomics to confirm or
refute that theory but there is this
other idea in science and biology this
inductive idea that description per se
reveals things that you did
know about and those things that reveals
generates a new round of hypothesis and
I think I'd like you to keep that in
mind as well it's a place where again
computer scientists could be very very
useful in how to turn this information
into data that could be used to generate
knowledge from the bottom up rather than
just test hypotheses that already exist
okay so does this make sense does
connectomics make sense and I mean this
in two senses one is as you're going to
see it's extraordinarily expensive and
difficult to do this kind of work and
secondly is what you get out of this is
it sensible you get out information but
information and understanding are not
the same thing so what does it make it
definitely makes data connect tommix
makes data but does it make sense does
it make things that make sense at the
moment I would say mostly not it makes
something that's scary in the sense you
see complexity with all of its warts
hanging out there and you just can't
turn it into some simple theory I'm
going to go a little bit more into why
this is so hard in the nervous system to
get simple theory out of connectomics
and that's because compared to all the
other organ systems in the body the
relationship between the physical
structure of the brain and its function
what it does is much more complicated
than anywhere else for example all
organs have cells of different types in
the kidney there are nine or ten types
of cells in the liver fifteen types of
cells but how many types of cells are
there in the brain a hint at how many is
comes by just looking at one organ which
is the retina this is a picture from
Maslin paper in 2001 and this at that
time there were 39 distinct types of
cells of neurons in the retina that
number is more than
doubled now and with connectomics that
number is increasing even more
there's just even in this one little
part of the brain which is just the
sensory reception of light that place
there are a huge number of different
kinds of nerve cells ganglion cells
amercan cells bipolar horizontal and
photoreceptors and these are different
types of a Makran cells different types
of ganglion cells and someday probably
not too far in the distant future we
will have pretty close to a complete
list of all the cell types in the retina
but yeah so in this case type is for
example a cell that has a shape where
its dendrites are found in particular
layers see the cell is got dendritic the
axon is here dendrites in many layers
where's this one in a narrower layers
this one only in the top layer this one
only in the bottom layer this one in to
narrow layers this one extends very long
each of these cells has a different
shape and when people record from these
cells they do something slightly
different with light coming in to the
eye so there's a whole bunch of
different types these are the output
cells of the retina that go to the
thalamus and the spirit colliculus all
of these cells have different function
and the same true for the amacrine cells
they have different shapes they connect
in different ways bipolar cells
horizontal cells and photoreceptors
photoreceptors are only three types
because we're try chromic one for each
color but there is this menagerie of
cell types that's what I mean by that is
that okay I'm not gonna talk much about
the visual system or you didn't talk
about retina at all yeah I mean you you
basically have information coming in
that's both related to the dynamics of
things moving the color the contrast the
shape is something looming going away
moving across the field these cells are
tuned to deal with different parts of
the visual scene not different places
because they're all tiled over the
entire retina but they extract different
kinds of information out of the visual
there are thousands and thousands of
experiments on on this people take a
piece of retina from certain animals
rabbit or axolotls salamanders where the
cells are big they record from them and
shine light and see how the cell
responds and then they have there's been
some Anatomy including am showing which
cells are connected to which other cell
types some of these are inhibitory some
of them are excitatory so there is
probably 50,000 that maybe that's too
many 20,000 papers on the red ok so
there's there are many many scientists
have spent their entire career working
in retina and yet don't feel like well
we're done every day they feel there's
more to do it's a remarkably complicated
and highly evolved system to extract
information about the visual world
[Music]
yes well their output chemistry of all
the ganglion cells they're only yeah
yeah there there are there's cholinergic
synapses there's GABAergic synapses and
they're glutamatergic synapses three
different neurotransmitters are common
in the retina and some of these cells
are are doing one one or two actually
are doing two types of neurotransmitter
very unusual in other parts of the brain
for the same cell to have more than one
neurotransmitter but yes there is
detailed information and genetics there
are genetic differences between these
cell types this is not a learned wiring
diagram this is one of those intrinsic
wiring diagrams designed by nature to
allow a young animal to begin to be able
to address what the world means by
having sensory perception all this and
this is drawing fish and mammals birds
are all very similar
vertebrates vertebrate retina okay so
that's one issue you're gonna get the
whole menagerie from the retina but then
you go to the cerebral cortex completely
different set of cells you go to the
amygdala or the brain stem the
cerebellum the spinal cord autonomic
ganglia the enteric nervous system in
the gut every one of those places have
their own set of nerve cell types so
there's an extraordinary diversity of
cell types there's nothing like this and
the rest of the body the diversity
diversity do you think the diversity is
cause of the need to wire them in a
certain way or because it actually
matters that they function in different
ways I mean is this just a way of
natively are they diverse because nature
with similar circuits you know that have
different component neurons
maybe function exactly the same parts of
the body facing the outside world like
the retina are evolving to take
information in that the animal needs to
survive so for example if the animal
needs to be able to see a circling hawk
and have enough resolution to tell the
difference between a circling hawk and a
circling duck and and chicks can do that
automatically can do that you have
through the eons of evolution built a
wiring diagram that does this and it
turns out the evolution of such wiring
diagrams generate diversity so in terms
of shape and what these cells are I
don't know why I don't know exactly what
the engine of that is other than if they
didn't have that mutation to cause that
extra diversity that would have gone
extinct so it is a kind of natural
selection of complex wiring diagrams
these thousands and thousands of
different types of cells other than as a
way of creating the connectivity if this
is you know if I look at a you know a
computer circuit I could just decide the
different types of transistors were
actually different just because they
would kind of look to build you know and
I would find similarities and these
would be just one issues publications I
mean in in the retina in the retina the
photoreceptors that respond best to red
light green light and blue light
not exactly but but roughly there's
overlap but those photoreceptors are in
different cells so there's a blue
channel or a shortwave channel a middle
wave channel in a long wavelength
channel biochemically those cells have
different rhodopsins they are designed
with the different intent and you
couldn't select you couldn't see those
colors if you didn't have those three
channels if you're a deer I think you
only have two channels that's why people
can wear blaze orange and not shoot each
other but the deer doesn't see them so
they're not sensitive to that color and
there are animals I think there are some
spiders that are for are there other
other animals that are for yeah there's
some animals that that have four colors
seven salmon yep so you know it's just
some you know evolution is an
extraordinarily powerful thing here and
to say why didn't they do it another way
is usually because this is the best way
if there were a better way biology had
plenty of time more than a billion years
to come up with a pedigree like like my
worry my worry is that if we have to you
know as computer scientist makes sense
of ten thousand different
themselves then that might be really
really complicated but it turned if it
turns out that these ten thousand cells
I could get just categorized at there
and there are actually only five things
that they all do even though they're
chemically different they do five things
that would simplify everyone it would
the world processors that you know we
can do things the other way until it
does yeah or we can do these kind of
RISC architectures which are really
simple they do the same thing with less
variability
this is a 30 watt supercomputer 30 Watts
nothing it's there's nothing like it
Intel is really good this is 30 watts
30 Watts a trillion synapses no I'm
saying I think there's a reason it's
done this way because saving energy is
essential it is really important and so
that's one of the constraints how to
make the most efficient use of biology
may be to use many different components
as opposed to in an industry where you
want to use the same component over and
over again that would be the way I would
put it it's dangerous to already assume
most of this is unnecessary if biology
thinks it is differentiation process so
robust that it creates these hundreds of
types and you know interconnected in the
most intricate ways I'm gonna tell you
about one of the ways cells wire up
relate to experience which is robust but
it is not related to genetics when it
comes to genetics it becomes
extraordinarily hard because genetics
itself that is the underlying
inheritance that gives rise to these
traits is based on a network of genes
which is also not well understood so
there's a deep you know mystery after
mystery after mystery and you end up
with this extraordinary complexity and
you know you just grin and bear it so if
you go down as far as C elegans which is
a very small worm that has 309 or
something like that neurons it's a very
very small nervous system it's only got
300 cells the problem is and person
sitting right in front of you can tell
you this your own who's been
reconstructing these cells is that these
cells are not simple in any sense of the
word they've been hyper evolved so one
cell probably has many functions so they
still do a lot but they do it with as
few cells as possible it's very hard you
could go back to maybe these nerve net
animals you know the little medusa type
animals where they just have a nerve net
of single cells that are interconnected
in a way that we are now just starting
to reconstruct i mean these are
happening but i am not sure we're gonna
get the answer there either i think one
way to divide it is I'm interested in
genetically based circuits
like canonical circuits and the cortex
like the circuit and the retina or I'm
interested in how information changes
circuits but no matter what the cells
are and that might be more addressable
because there's probably not an infinite
number of ways to change circuits based
on experience even though there may be
an infinite number of ways genetics have
changed cells types so one could
separate these two fields at some point
if anything more complicated
well they are roughly the same from one
room to another during development they
change their wiring but yes they're more
kind of there is a canonical circuit
supposedly in the worm but it's not
something trivial it's hyper connected
it's cells are connected to many more
cells than you might have done if you
were the engineer as opposed to nature
actually the cortex let me just say that
you know 80% of the cells are more or
less of one type I don't want to
overstate the similarity among different
pyramidal neurons but that may be a
little provide a little bit of relief
that if 80% of the total was parental
Deron's and then 10% is a particular
type of inner neuron and 8% is this
other type of Pentagon it's a little
less you know terrifying and the
circuits have a great deal of regularity
if they didn't you wouldn't study them
what would be the point of study one
dendrite if it wasn't anything like the
next one over I don't know the answer
actually to that I really don't I mean
maybe you're right that it really is a
tractable problem but even if you reduce
the complexity by a factor of a hundred
it would be an intractable problem if
you reduce it by a thousand it would be
an intractable problem it's just
fundamentally so much going on I don't
think you can reduce maybe you can say
there are neurons that are excitatory
and inhibitory
if you know that you can explain
everything the brain does maybe so I
don't know I doubt it I think at every
level there's complexity here and so to
try to say well computer scientists
don't have to worry about this too much
because it's not that bad I think it's
worse not it's worse than anything not
not no matter how bad I tell you it is I
think it's going to be worse and that's
the opportunity because there's no one
else in the world other than a computer
scientist who could deal with this one
type of device a NAND gate all right so
you know it's the figuring out process
that's made more difficult but it's not
like you can't build the brain unless
you have a thousands of weird types of
objects it's just if you want to build a
30 watt brain it may be that you need to
absolutely select each and every element
to be it's maximally efficient and and
that's the magic of these brains that
sit in our head I know we have 10
minutes I've gotten through 1% of my
slide so let crystal good
yeah I mean right you're facing it even
in your own field and even humans are to
blame in this case these were not
there's not genetics it's truly a human
inspired belt okay so many different
size scales the brain is another problem
with brains is that it it has you know
planning in the front vision and the
occipital lobe balance in the cerebellum
so there's all this sort of macroscopic
structure that is important for brain
function and then when you get up to a
little area factor of 10 bigger picture
here there's the gray matter where the
nerve cells are and the white matter
which is unfortunately painted pink here
which is where the big axon bundles that
connect cells from one part of the brain
is to another if you zoom up another
factor of 10 this is what a single
pyramidal neuron looks like it can
extend all the way from the bottom to
the top of the cerebral cortex layer has
all these dendrites and then it has one
axon going out you zoom up again by a
factor of 10 the dendrites are
complicated in that they have a division
of labor they have these little things
called spines sticking out of them and
shafts where there are no spines and
there are typically different kinds of
synapses on the spines and shafts the
spines get excitatory synapses that try
to force information out of the cell out
its axon and the inhibition
sits on the shafts and its job is to
basically short-circuit any electrical
circuit going down this way to shut
things off
so there's inhibition and excitation and
when they're active is important and
then at the level of a spine there is
finally the synapse and now I show you
actually an electron micrograph of a
synapse I I see this very clearly
because I look at these all the time but
I'm gonna color them in to make it clear
this is a dendrite in cross-section just
cut so that this dendrite is in
cross-section and here is the neck of a
spine it has a little apparatus in it
those lines are significant and then up
against it is a cross-section of an axon
that's filled with these little circles
which are neurotransmitter packets their
synaptic vesicles and those are the
vesicles that release their
neurotransmitter at this interface to
cause an electrical change to take place
in the dendrite flow into the whole
dendrite and down towards the cell body
so this is the synaptic connection and
this is a one-way communication that is
the dendrite is not changing the firing
pattern of the axon here the axon is
changing the activity of the Dendera
okay so that's you can see stuff like
this at high resolution you can see
every synaptic vesicle but there's a
problem here and that is there's
important information about the brain at
every one of these levels at this level
you probably know about this technique
called functional magnetic resonance
imaging where the resolution you get
images like I don't think I put it in
there you get images that just have hot
spots where the resolution of the image
is one cubic millimeter and a human
brain has about a million cubic
millimeters and you can see where blood
flow is at this one cubic millimeter
resolution at this level you are
resolving things that nanometers this is
a 500 cubic nanometer voxel whereas this
is a cubic millimeter voxel
voxel is 2,000 trillion times smaller
than this voxel that is if you wanted to
get the full resolution of the wiring
diagram at this level you would need two
thousand terabytes or two petabytes for
every voxel at this level of resolution
so a human brain you would need two
petabytes times a million which is just
what two million petabytes yottabytes is
that this so that would give you a whole
brain that's a lot of data I don't know
how that compares with the digital
content of the world but it's up there
yeah okay so that's another I'm not
trying to scare you but that's the
reality of trying to get a whole wiring
diagram of the human brain I'm going to
I we have to take a break now and I'll
think about whether I'm gonna talk about
Brainbow insights or go right to
electron microscopy I think maybe when
we come back I'll go right to electron
microscopy so we'll we'll skip this
development and just go on if that's
okay so let's take a break for a half an
hour you can discuss more and then we'll
come back
[Applause]